let's do some solid geometry volume
problems so they tell us shown as a
triangular prism and so there's a couple
of types of three-dimensional figures
that deal with triangles this is what a
triangular prism looks like or has a
triangle on one two faces and they're
kind of separated they're kind of
have rectangles in between the other
types of triangular three-dimensional
figures is you might see pyramids this
would be a rectangular pyramid because
it has it has a rectangular or it has a
square base just like that you could
also have a you could also have a
triangular pyramid where alt which is
literally every side is a triangle so
stuff like that but this over here is a
triangular prism i don't want to get too
much into the shape classification if
the base of the triangle b is equal to
seven the height of the triangle h is
equal to three and the length of the
prism l is equal to four
what is the total volume of the prism so
they're saying that the base is equal to
seven so this base
this right over here is equal to base is
equal to seven the height of the
triangle is equal to three so this right
over here
this distance right over here h is equal
to three
and the length of the prism is equal to
four so i'm assuming it's this dimension
over here is equal to four so length is
equal to four
so in this situation what you really
just have to do is figure out the area
of this triangle right over here we
could figure out the area of this
triangle and then multiply it by how
much you go deep so multiply it by this
length so the volume is going to be the
area of this triangle let me do it in
pink the area of this triangle we know
that the area of a triangle is one-half
times the base times the height so the
area this area right over here is going
to be one-half
times the base
times the height and then we're going to
multiply it by like kind of our depth of
this triangular prism so we have a depth
of four so then we're going to multiply
that times
the four times this depth
times the four
and we get let's see one half times four
is two
so this these guys cancel out you'll
just have a two and then two times three
is six six times seven is 40
is 42 and it would be in some type of
cubic unit so if these were in i don't
know centimeters it would be centimeters
cubed but they're not making us focus on
the units in this problem let's do
another one
shown as a cube if each side
of the cube or if each side is of equal
length x equals three
what is the total volume of the cube so
each side is equal length x which
happens to equal three so this side is
three
this side over here x is equal to three
every side x is equal to three so it's
actually the same exercise as the
triangular prism it's actually a little
bit easier when you're dealing with the
cube where you really just want to find
the area of this surface right over here
and this is pretty straightforward this
is just a square or you could it would
be the base times the height or since
they're the same it's just three times
three so the volume is going to be the
area of this surface three times three
times the depth
times the depth
and so we go three deep so times
so times three and so we get three times
three times three it's just 27. or you
might recognize this from exponents this
is the same thing as three to the third
power and that's why sometimes if you
have something to the third power
they'll say you cubed it because
literally to find the volume of a cube
you take the length of one side and you
multiply that number by itself three
times one for each dimension one for the
length the width and or i guess the
height the length and the depth
depending on how you want to define them
so it's literally just 3 times 3 times
3.